first we sent sally harmio around town
to assess some of the damage
across the valley from last night's
storms she is an anthem right now
with the latest hey sally
ted yesterday's storms were amongst the
scariest for
many neighbors in this anthem
neighborhood they tell me they've never
experienced something like that
strong gusts of 60 to 70 miles per hour
reported take a look at this tree the
homeowner here tells me
crews will be cleaning up the mess until
tomorrow
now earlier today as you mentioned ted
there were multiple flash flood warnings
in effect affecting the southwest
including summerlin perrum
sandy valley and emericus valley one
area that saw heavy rain this morning
the red rock visitors center and near
blue diamond and durango some cars
driving through flooded roadways
roadways others choosing to turn around
nevertheless
many are still left shocked
five years i've been here i've never
seen a storm like this
the wind and you know i was glad when it
was over but then when i came out this
morning to find this tree it's like it's
been uprooted
linda says neighbors have been very
cautious in the area she is glad
no one got hurt now i reached out to
multiple tree services
and they tell me they are extremely busy
right now
storm chances are still in the forecast
for tonight
we'll have more on that on 8 news now
reporting live here in henderson sally
jaramillo 8 news now